this past weekend
[Music]
must be video alright
yeah yeah
come on now it's just Monday
come on man we can do it
[Music]
if you'll do it I'll do it guys if
you'll do it I'll do it
it's just Monday that's all it is if
you're listening to this on Monday if
not it could be Tuesday if you're doing
a different day and also listening to
this at the same time and welcome to
this past weekend and happy whatever day
it is I mean this the thing is is that
this is it this is the day whatever it
whatever I don't care if it's you know
if it is the year 2018 which is when
this has been recorded and taped or if
it's you might be listening to this into
but this is the day whatever this is it
so whatever it is is what it is so at
this point it's just how am I gonna deal
with it how am I gonna look at it
because let me tell you this today
probably showed up with claws on you
know and with sharp panties on and today
probably showed up beaten wanting to be
wild
you know today probably showed up with a
like a [ __ ] dude with no arms and
sharp teeth that wants to fight and how
are you gonna deal with today that's the
question
because that is what's in our control
and I'm saying they might have a missile
headed right at you or headed right at
your cousin or headed right at somebody
you don't even know maybe a step cousin
or a distant relative or somebody one of
your parents used to [ __ ] when they were
in college they might have a missile
headed right at you're headed right at
them but what are you gonna do you gotta
you gotta find a way to celebrate living
in the meantime as the missiles head our
direction we got to hit that joy you
know if you got a cut on a beautiful
song under the music player or you got
to do something you know if you got to
watch a you know somebody do the dougie
or somebody do you know a fancy dance on
the internet or you got to do whatever
you got to do you got to tickle somebody
that's already probably got high blood
pressure and watch them laugh and then
also [ __ ] off probably coughing then
struggle whatever you have to do
it's just a matter of you got to find
that joy for today you got to find it
because sometimes life's gonna give you
that [ __ ] limonada
and that's Spanish lemonade baby and
what are you gonna do huh you're gonna
sit there and be like man they don't
like Luminato mmm no you got to find a
way to thrive you got to find a way to
just convince your taste buds that today
yes lemon ara for daddy and lean will
not afford ah mama so let's just let's
have a good perspective today guys
whatever day it is and let's get into it
thank you guys for joining me thank you
guys for being a part of my celebrating
living
[Music]
that's it
let's have some fun while we all die a
little dark it's a little dark I know
but that's my Spencer Jacob growl and if
you're hearing me come in a little bit
wacky there a little echoey it's because
I am in Portland Oregon and I'm down
here at the nines hotel they got a fancy
hotel down here called the nines and I'm
staying down here and I took the I took
the and how I do it when I'm on the road
I put a picture up on my Instagram but
how I do it is I'll take the the light
the lamp covers off and put them you
know put the lamps close enough and I
get the video camera set up so we can
have video and audio and then and we
start putting this hitter together
speaking of hitters great block pizza
they're always with us you know sometime
you have a devil on your shoulder and
that devil is he's got pork ribs or he
got you know birthday cake day-old
birthday cake you know we're two day old
but then on that other shoulder you got
that that uh you got that Italian you
got that that fire that fiery Italian
with that spine with a spine that's uh
that's kind of fancy you know some
people spines go straight and some
people spines go side to side they call
a scoliosis I call it spine flavor some
people bone structure got that built-in
torque and that's what I call it and
that's what I that's what I see when I
see someone with that scoliosis I'm like
damn you know daddy's got that osteo
fa'sho stirs you know daddy's spine has
already got that dance move built into
it and that's what you get with that
gray block hitter you know that Devils
on your shoulder with the pork ribs and
with the you know the the day old
birthday cake that has maybe expired
frosting on it you know frosting that
should have been eaten a year or two ago
but then on that other shoulder you got
that beautiful Italian delivery boy and
he don't have a whole pie he might have
he might have a slice wouldn't that be
beautiful a delivery man shows up to
your door just with that slice boy oh
he's like and you open the door and you
can't even the Italian man that is so he
came
he's so sexy you can't even [ __ ] get
a good look at him
that's how sexy that man is and he might
have a shirt on he might not have a
shirt on
he might have three shirts on you don't
even know he's moving so fast but so
slow at the same time and you know you
ordered pizza but maybe you didn't may
be your heart did and you look and you
think he's gonna have maybe like he's
got a hot bag he's got that one them hot
bags it's actually a box and some of
them pizza people they carry the hot box
you know you're like damn what's in
there you know and he opens it up and
first you see just a bunch of steam come
flowing out maybe a small horse comes
running out of the bag or two horses and
they've been drinking a lot of water and
they look well nourished and you're like
[ __ ] this horses were having fun in that
bag what's going on in there and then he
reaches in you think he's gonna pull out
a whole pizza pie this fast slow Italian
you think he's gonna pull out an entire
L pia l piazza de italiano but no he
pulls out just one slice and you open
your mouth to ask a question but before
you can get the question out he just he
reaches his small little bitty long sexy
Italian hand and just drops that pizza
right in to your [ __ ] loud face hole
and your eyes closed and you go to sleep
and you have dreams of pure joy you have
dreams of the Lord sitting on a cloud
playing with Barbie dolls and eaten
fresh frosting and that is that great
block hitta their link is always with us
in our information you can check them
out that's GRE y BL Ock dot-com gray
block or gray block pizza I don't know
the link is in the frickin info don't
ask me but they're always with us get
that I'm in Portland guys I'm in
Portland Oregon and man what a what a
what a wheat man I'm at that I I'm gonna
tell you right about the gate I'm I
thank some people man I want to thank a
couple of fat Gary came out fat Gary
came out with his wife brought with his
lean wife
Daniel big Daniel came gutter smut to
twelve came cat Busch earnest to else I
got a couple spice rack dead family
Gucci eleven came out Allen small Pat
everybody came out and I'm grateful and
I'm thank I'm thankful to you guys for
making my experience here a good one and
it has been a good one man
we went to Harvey's comedy club if you
haven't been there a lot of my listeners
it was their first time a lot of my fans
it was their first time there and and it
was my first time there man and we got
through it and we got through the
weekend
and I just want to thank you guys so
many cool cats came out people drove in
from Canada
Detroit other countries different places
somebody voted in they said some dude
had you know he he said you know they
have a coatrack room where you check
your coat some dude checked in a to bow
doors like who in the [ __ ] is this
viking but he made it he made it out to
the show and he said he couldn't bring
his family but he brought pictures of
his family and it made me kind of
question him a little bit but you know
what in the end I'm just gonna believe
him believe that he has a family but man
we had a blast we had a bet we had a
blast over there in Portland Oregon and
everybody came out and I just want to
thank you it was a good time and I got
to tell you people were asking did you
visit the hamster ranch and hold on I'm
just making sure this audio is okay
people were asking did you visit the
hamster ranch and I'm gonna tell you
this yes I did I went out there and
visited with the hamster rancher himself
mr. Austin Robinette and I'm gonna see
if I have his call here right here
and where his hamsters his coal anyhow I
should have a ride here I don't have it
but anyhow hey Austin called in a while
back and he said hey man I am a damn
hamster rancher you know and I need you
out here you would love it out here
and he's out here ranch in HAMP's and so
I went out there and I pull up and look
man I was a little bit nervous cuz look
let's be honest 9 out of 10 times
somebody says hey come
out to the suburbs or rural area rural
Oregon and you know I'll be out here
with five or 6,000 hamsters pretty much
nine out of ten times you're gonna get
murdered nine out of ten time go do it
you don't believe me sign up some of you
guys are sitting there like come on man
90% of the time I'm gonna get murdered
yes you might so I'm not saying that I'm
a damn miracle but I'm saying I caught
that lucky non murdering hamster rancher
and so Austin I met him up out there and
he's a man he's a you know he's about a
medium man if you had to think of a man
who's a medium a healthy medium then you
would be thinking about him and I got
out there and I was nervous you know and
uh and next thing you know they welcomed
me inside he was out there he has
children so you got children out there
and we see the children you know things
are pretty legit because a lot of
murderers if somebody's a murderer they
don't bring their children around you
know murderers they usually do family
stuff murder stuff completely separate
but I'll tell you this I I got into
their main kind of and I don't want to
call it a warehouse because I don't want
to sound make sound make their business
sound like unpro
on like like not you know legit or not
healthy or not I mean these animals were
all well cared for it seemed like they
had a mall out there
they had them Swarovski's them Russians
you know they had I didn't see anything
they had some Syrians I saw probably
about I'm not even joking
maybe 1,100 Syrian HAMP's out there gang
gang I saw they had a the Campbell
Dwarfs I mean they looked they had Angus
they had the Black Angus dude you know
they had the Fibonacci's they had
everything they had everything out you
can't even imagine
I saw six thousand hamsters right there
I mean it was like dang I mean if Noah's
Ark would have pulled up it would have
been a [ __ ]
because there's no way you were gonna
pick two just to put on a boat they were
all beautiful and I was in heaven
and this man Tony Jones met me out there
you know my lady friend accompanied me
out there and we made it out there and
and we just checked him out and it was
awesome you know the lady I think
Christie or Chris does her name I also
don't want to give out too much of their
personal information because they
welcomed me into their environment but
I'll tell you this this man Austin
Robinette and [ __ ] I just gave his full
name
but this man Austin Robinette he's a
HAMP rancher and man he took they
welcomed me in and next thing you know
look I'll tell you this if you would
have put me in a in a in a in a bath tub
you could have completely covered me
with hamsters if I was laying down you
could have completely covered me with
hamsters probably 40 times that's how
many there were so I'm just telling you
there was six seven thousand they were
and look there was a lot of more breast
feeding and they were [ __ ] hugging
and a lot of them like you know you're
walking down the rows and they're in
these little you know they're in these
um you know cages or aquariums and I'm
not selling cages this [ __ ] ain't like
the Green Mile you know it's not like
I'm walking through there and they got
you know one of them's beating a cup
against the rails or something or
throwing you know skeet out of the damn
cage or something like in Silence of the
Lambs it's not like silence of a HAMP's
you know where they got a shorten a
short man in the distance licking his
lips with a hockey mask on talking about
wine you know no there was nothing wild
like that you just had man I can't even
express to you the joy that I felt and
for me like I've never been a pet lover
and I you know and I know that hurts
some people to hear about daddy I grew
up in an environment where you didn't
have I didn't nobody had a [ __ ] pet
when I was young
okay you know I saw a blind kid one time
get chased by two bats that's where
really the first experience ever had
with animals and that [ __ ] is and then I
got attacked by
dogs on one of my birthday's I got
attacked by cats on one of my birthday's
a cat came off this roof one time of a
camper and [ __ ] got me right around
my clavicle when we were about to go to
the river one time couldn't even go you
know how to get rabies tetanus shots all
that at so I haven't had good experience
and nobody my neighborhood had nobody
had a pet
nobody had a [ __ ] P et a pet is
something you touch that is an animal
okay
people had animals you know they had
that dog that live over there by
Wellington's house but Danny
Wellington's
have you seen that dog people like is
that Danny's dog [ __ ] no that ain't
Danny's dog okay that dogs from
somewhere else that dog could be from
Nebraska it's mixed the dog is mixed you
know it looks kind of half
you know maybe half Scottish half
african-american and that thing's out
there [ __ ] people up by Danny
Wellington's then even that's nobody's
dog I'm the first time I ever saw a pet
indoors and that was a pet that's a dog
you can touch that doesn't it's not
gonna um you know ah that's not gonna
that's not gonna try and attack you or
wrangle you or get some blood out of
your body with its teeth yeah we didn't
have all that so when I see these people
come you know and I see you know and I'm
in the safe confines of this of this
ranch man it just made me for the first
time my life I kind of felt what it was
like to be an animal lover really and
you know and that shows me that a lot of
times it's just about it's just about
that safety feeling that safety around
animals and feeling I guess you know I
grew up in such fear of him that I
wasn't able to love it's hard to love
from a place of fear it's really really
hard and that's one thing I've even
found I'm not trying to get emo here but
one thing I found about myself as a
person now when I was a child I was I
must have been so fearful as a child
that it was hard for me to learn about
love because I couldn't you it's really
hard to love from a place of fear
because love is just it's a lot of trust
love is just as much trust as you can
put together I mean it's just a really
fancy fancy buffet of trust you know you
got a little bit of trust pudding and
you got some you know uh you know you
got some trust ruffles and you got some
trust truffles and you got trust flakes
and trust cracklins over here and then
you got the bowl trust and a baked trust
and there Myrna learn trust and that's
that trust buffet that's love but man
when you don't have that growing up and
you feel fearful then it's hard to love
things it's hard to love people it's
hard to love yourself really but that's
what happened to me with them animals
you know every time I went outdoors it
was [ __ ] you know Gang Gang son who
wants a piece of daddy you know fit you
know trying to punch it these crows that
were trying to attack us or you know
people you know dogs coming at us you
know not to mention the lice belt don't
even tell me I didn't grow up in the
lice belt you know next thing you know
you're walking with a friend next you
know he hits the dirt and he's
scratching his head you don't know what
happened you think invisible lightning
got him no it did it no it didn't that's
lice and that's the devils invisible
crawling lightning and that's head lice
and so it just you know it was hard to
it was hard to love animals when you
couldn't trust them because I'm gonna be
honest if people want to say all animals
all animals aren't trustworthy and all
that let's don't get into that [ __ ] okay
some of these animals are out there just
trying to catch it just get that next
hit to buy that next gram okay to cop
that next piece of ass not every animal
is nice you know if you remember Roger
Rabbit and they have those three or four
weasels as sneaky weasels trying to
trying to bang that chick with the red
hair yeah
remember Scrooge McDuck the beagle boys
their dogs dude yeah and they were bank
robbers and I know you're like oh those
are drawings I know other drawings but
they're based on real life you idiot and
that's what I'm saying not all animals
are great so you don't trust him you
don't have that trust but when I was out
there with these with Austin and this
gang man it
I mean you can't even believe the joy
and I'm making a video I'll put it up on
patreon this week and that's not I'm not
I'm not making it just for patreon
patreon people but I am gonna say that
uh you know I you know I got to do
something for them is a lot of support a
lot of support there's a lot of support
so but man it was I'm trying to think of
what else happened dude I almost
couldn't even hear when I was air I was
having so much fun just being around
them all and you get up to the cages and
you just you know some um you know they
just you know some look like they speak
Spanish and some of them look like they
you know might have been homosexual or
just trying to meet another little you
know man hamster I mean everything yet
everything going on and they had rabbits
and then the families the family you
know some of the families live it on
there on premises and the people that
owned the joint they used to both sell
tropical fish and they met it like a
dang a big fish mixer so I mean that's
that's animals right there bringing
people together you know when you're out
there too big fish make sure you guys
are standing on the side of a tank next
thing you know y'all are both you know
boggle in the same carp or whatever and
then and then fast forward seven years
you guys were running a hamster ranch
out there outside of Oregon so it was
just it was unbelievable and that's the
power of podcasting too because Austin
hit me up he just said hey man you know
I love the podcast you know I want to
know what's going on and I'm here is
what I do here I got the call right here
let's see if we can listen to it this is
the call that came in originally from
Austin hey Theo my name is Austin I'm
from Oregon up here just hop up for one
I was looking to call so I heard about
you through two Rogen's John Geoghan and
it's pretty funny so Thank You Austin I
appreciate that and this is his original
call keep going I checked out your
podcast fairly recently actually the one
night I was working on the forum that I
live on and
I'm working away and I heard you on your
other podcast allegedly talking about
hamster farms and I thought it was crazy
because I live on hamster ranch and I
was right in the middle of feed the
hamster so that's kind of freaking out I
just it's in there by myself feeding
hamsters listening to you Wow and you
would think from hearing that that the
man's gonna be a murderer you know I was
in there by myself feeding hamsters but
no man he was a good man and Austin I
thank you so much Austin came out to the
show on Saturday night with two of his
friends and we everybody had a great
time and and I'm just grateful we'll try
it we'll try to check in with Austin
here and there and see if we can you
know have him be an occasional guest
here on the hear on this past weekend
but it was just you know that's the
power of podcasting he hears that he
reaches out and next thing you know you
know we're out there really enjoying
ourselves out there and just getting to
be around all these beautiful little
just damn just [ __ ] floor bears I
mean just spirited spirited it was just
like just like a damn just like magic I
mean it was just like magic it was like
somebody just took a whole [ __ ] bag
of just magic dust and just buried it
inside of a bunch of a little bitty
animals asses or something or eyes or
hearts and let those little animals out
loose into the world I mean I had six or
seven thousand hamsters within reach and
you can't even imagine how many that is
that's what's crazy about it but we had
a great time and and that's what that's
what uh that's what went on that's what
went on right there so that was Oregon
you know we were over there at the
comedy club that was Oregon and and I
have some other dates coming up I want
to let you guys know I'll be in La Jolla
this weekend February 16th through the
18th at the Comedy Store that's near San
Diego I'll be at fantasy Springs Casino
the 23rd and 24th of February I'll be in
Tacoma the 15th and 16th when we got
trickling Mickey's showing up we're
gonna set him up with a girl the 17th
I'll be out there and Spokane
oh wait I'm sorry I got a text it's
spoken out there and spoke in Washington
and then I'll be at levity live in
Oxnard February 23rd through the 25th
I'll be at bananas comedy I don't know
where that's at somewhere in New Jersey
and that's April 20th and 21st as of
right now what else and we had some
great calls that came in I'm gonna get
to him I wanted to first one I want to
talk about this as well you know we
started off talking about you know
perspective and how do we look at the
day you know and and it's funny because
Austin the hemp the hipster rancher and
I know I keep going back to him but well
first of all I'll tell you how it's
evolved you know when I was when I was
growing up and I worked you know cuz I
grew up in the stray animal bill and you
know my one of my first job selling
hamsters and guinea pigs outside of
concerts and and raves and so when I was
doing it when I was working for these
men that had this outfit outside of my
town they had you know it looked like a
little farm you know short gates very
small gates and almost looked like a
Christmas village you know but without
the courthouse and the firehouse it was
just like a little fence and they had
kind of this kind of mesh top that they
put on it and all the hamsters and a
guinea pig separate would stay in those
so you could go out and see you know
it'd be like 20 square feet you know
we're for whatever that is 400 feet or
what I don't know how you do square feet
but and you look out and it would just
be this big you know these it's just
like a herd of them you know and you can
and you know and say if you come in and
what you know why one side of the one
wall of the little bitty fence I mean
the fence was only maybe five inches
high if you come by one side of the
fence it all run to the other side you
know and sometimes you could hear them
at night and you know like around winter
time they'd all go to like to the south
side of the of the little you know
square footage or whatever but that's
just nature you know those animals
migrate even in little places like that
and now when I went to see when I went
to see this up this new farm they were
all in you know little each had not each
had but you know however many were
supposed to have their separate
enclosures they did and you know you'd
have the babies in there and the mother
like feeding the babies and you know
you'd walk past the different little
cages and sometimes you felt like a
peeping tom like you'd look in and you
know when I'm gonna be kind of skeet not
in the corner or you know a mother would
be you know have her bare breasts out
feeding the little HAMP's or you'd have
like you know you have a fat one in the
corner kind of you know maybe eating uh
eating a Ricci cup or something that he
found himself that he snuck out and got
out at night I mean it was oh it was
amazing man I mean I was just so lit up
on on the environment but it's changed a
lot I mean back in the day it was one
big group thing and now it's you know
it's individualized a little bit more
and there's a certain wall where you
know they're all mating and doing sex
and they played music on that wall and
they had a little bit of I'm not sure
what it was I think it was Kid Rock
they were playing because you know let's
be honest do it I mean some animals
might make make sex and do sex to
certain types of tunes you know jazz are
easy listening or you know Lionel
Richard but but if you're going to get
some real rodents because hamsters in
that road and Kingdom if you're gonna
get some real rodents to frickin get
down and do a little bit of doggy style
you're gonna have to put on some [ __ ]
kid rock you know are some Waylon
Jennings and they had a lot of they had
a lot of good stuff going on there maybe
even some who sang that song would they
go down on you in a theater do you
suspect a Lachlan lay would they have
your baby I think it's some Eastwood or
something I'm not sure but you got to
play something like that with that
action in it to really get hamsters two
to two men have sex but it was amazing
and I'll put that video up I'll put it
up on patreon and then a few days later
we'll release it on just for everyone
but I want to thank you guys so much for
your support a little bit of news
a little bit of news came in I'm gonna
read this story cuz people are talking
about the dark arts and the tour that's
coming up is the dark arts tour and it's
gonna focus specifically on dark arts
and and we'll be we're getting some
artwork made right now for that
I appreciate some of the submissions
that have come in and we've had a lot of
music submissions and we're also gonna
do an episode where we roast people's
music so if you have an issue you don't
want me doing it you know most people
are emailed and asked if it's okay
nothing too harsh but just funny stuff
you know like places I can see the music
bein but here's a news here's the news
here's the news okay here we go
the masturbating game in Germany is
killing many according to a recent study
masturbation kills up to a hundred
Germans a year I'm not surprised
just for some reason not surprised about
that
the study also uncovered the bizarre
ways people have died pleasuring
themselves one man wearing a pantyhose a
raincoat and a diving suit as well as a
plastic bag over his head
died in Hamburg after sitting next to a
heater and trying to melt slices of
cheese on his body man and I am so
hungry right now that's the craziest
thing how crazy is that another man in
Hall H al L II was found dead with
Christmas tree lights clamped to his
nipples having apparently tried to
stimulate himself by electrocution and
can you blame a guy I mean imagine first
of all it's already awesome have enough
having a boner okay
that's already pretty much about a
hundred and fifty percent awesome
imagine having an electric powered boner
awesomer and think about this the reason
why a lot of men are doing this kind of
stuff is because women are behind
electric Weiner wieners you go to these
stores go to some of these stores adult
world a sex town or whatever all this
[ __ ] off the interstate adults shop
video adult video that's
all people selling electric wieners and
thumb fake innards and all kinds of
stuff fake vaginas fake anuses they're
selling piece of anus out there and it's
met some of them are the older ones are
metal like a malleable but still what
the [ __ ] it's not right you know it's
not right and so I'm not surprised that
men in germany are trying to you know
stimulate themselves by electrocution
what they're trying to do is compete
with these modern-day dicks and you know
you know battery-powered [ __ ] and all
of that electro dicks that are out there
available on amazon because if you know
say if this say if you know the girl
down the street big Samantha okay and
you know big Samantha at night you know
everybody's on the same power grid on
y'all street and on Saturday night
around 12:30 a.m. Sunday morning or
12:30 p.m. Saturday night you you know
your power goes down a little bit your
lamps get a little lower cuz yeah
Samantha is down the street and she's
revving up that wiener you know she
plugged in that super powered you know
that veiny angels 7000 or whatever it's
called you know she got that veiny angel
the 7000 plugged into the wall and she's
taking a hot dose you know hunting that
gasm man that in every man in the
neighborhood you see your lamp go down a
little bit the wattage goes from a
hundred to 70 and then you feel less
than you feel like you can't compete so
I'm not surprised that men are out there
trying to get their you know electricity
into their body and into their penises
and the men are out there cooking cheese
on their on their chest or whatever that
other guys do when that [ __ ] seems weird
it's like dude either just trying maybe
he was auditioning for Top Chef I
wouldn't be surprised if that's
something you know see a man out there
that's trying to cook a slice of cheese
on his chest and that [ __ ] is mildly
erotic isn't it I didn't think it was
going to be I mean I would definitely
watch uh you know I'll watch a lady
you know I'd watch a lady you know warm
up a couple of cookies on her onerous on
her hot tits for sure but also I gotta
say mildly erotic is also a man kind of
slowly melting a piece of cheese on his
bare chest but that masturbating game in
Germany is killing a lot of these dark
artists that's what the article says and
you can learn about that more if you go
out there and read about it I don't know
where to find that but we did have a
caller that came in about it and I want
to hear him right here here we go
hey being with Vincent here from Germany
just what are the cold hotline about we
haven't even thanked you for calling
Vincent from Germany and this is this
might be our first true German on the on
the on the hotline and I respect true I
respect true Germans you know and I met
a man one time there was a true German
and he said he never eats candy canes
out a season and I always respected that
about him that's true German onward
Vincent thank you for calling like for
man it has gotten really tough so here I
don't even know what to do anymore I'm
kind of lost
and they're introducing all these laws
now like they're certain to find man 350
years for whistling and woman and asking
them for phone number Wow
you hear it guys you hear what Vincent's
saying that in Germany they can't even
whistle at a woman what if you just
happen to have your lips pursed and
somebody punches you in the stomach and
a bunch of air goes out of your face and
a hot chick is walking by I'm sure a lot
of men have use that if they have had to
go to court use that excuse but that's
only gonna last a couple times you know
before they just say nope not that
either everybody's going to jail three
hundred and fifty dollars for asking a
woman for her number
well you know what we need the problem
is here let's listen to the rest of your
call first please Vincent homeward I
don't know what to do sweet and they
even started like you need like a truth
Khamsin from the women like you need a
little contract you need your lawyer to
drop a little contract before you can
have sexual intercourse with the woman I
don't know it's just going crazy Wow
and you think the Swedish man I wouldn't
odd odd buying a couple of Swedish
chicks with zero documents honestly I
mean there's definitely some chicks from
some places rubbing like glue see some
let's see some documents
you know let's see let's see some
identification but man you you you you
you know you show up with a wheelbarrow
full of Swedish ladies at my place I'm
not asking for paperwork but I hear the
pain in your voice Vince and I do I do
hear the pain in your voice let's hear
more just wanted to hear your opinion on
this we already have a giant
masturbation problem in Germany and I
think it's just gonna get worse like we
have a hundred germs being killed
through masturbation every year and I
wanted to tell you this because that's
kind of funny there was a young man he
was a panty hose a raincoat and a diving
suit as well as a plastic bag over his
head and he died sitting next to a
heater and trying to melt that cheese on
his body and I hear you laughing there
and um and I appreciate that call we
were just talking about that and some of
you listeners are gonna see well look
that's kind of weird dear you're just
talking about that and now this man was
well I was reading the article and then
people know that this is about the dark
arts in the title of the article it's
called the masturbating game in Germany
is killing these dark artists so on the
hotline we happen to have a call from
this man and and he's citing that source
as well Vincent thanks for that you know
I mean gosh these men are dying
these men are dying do you hear this
guys men are jerking off and dying
melting trying to cook cheese on their
[ __ ] naked bodies they don't know
what to do that's the problem and where
the women that are standing up for men
that's what I don't understand why
aren't there more
who were just standing up and saying
look I just I'm okay with how men are
there's a lot of good men out there can
we quit looking at the just the bad man
and can we start honoring the good men
that are out there or can we just start
accepting men for you know with some of
the faults that they have and I'm not
saying severe faults I'm not saying you
know these guys like Harvey Weinstein or
Jeffrey Dahmer I'm not talking about
that kind of [ __ ] but I am talking about
you know maybe a guy you know he doesn't
you know get his toenails taken care of
you know or he you know he cries outside
about our back of the house or out front
of the house and his truck once in a
while that doesn't make him a bad person
you know or he doesn't want to use the
recycling bin that doesn't make him
Satan's little buddy
okay it just makes it maybe that you
know that that's what's going on for him
you know it's like Manolis you have
these over feminists who they don't want
men to do they don't want anything from
men they want to see men fail and so
they are pushing this agenda that men
are no good that men aren't half of the
reason that any of us exist in the world
you know I think there's a lot of good
men out there
and if there aren't good I know that
they're trying which is a hundred which
is to me is 95% of are you making that
effort you know what's what's your end
game is your in game to be a good person
you on that track you know Tom Brady
they were talking to had this article
the other day about Tom Brady and how he
said at a certain point is life his goal
was to be 1% better than the day before
and that really stood that really that
set that that's at with me like man I
think I think I can do that I can be 1%
better than yesterday I think I can do
that but I'm sorry Vince and I'm sorry
that this is you know that this is
affecting you guys you know a hundred
Germans a year
who knows how many Swedish French we
don't need all the French but whatever
you know we don't want to lose you know
I mean it's just sad you know how many
men in Reno Nevada are dying each year
cuz they're you know jumping off a
building and trying to come at the same
time you know what's going on it's a
tough time for men it's a tough time you
just got to stand on your two legs and
know what you're doing is okay you got
to quit causing if you're rape and stop
raping if you're racist
stop racist you know we we at some point
we also do have to be brave and move
forward we got to get clean we got to
tighten up it's okay to ask for
forgiveness you know sometimes you're
just one you're just all you are is an
ask for for all yours and ask for
forgiveness away from having a clean
slate from having a clean heart
sometimes that's all you are
you're so close but yeah I had a great
time I felt so welcome up here in Oregon
and I will come back you know I cannot I
want to thank Brendan Schaub as well
from fighter in the kid who you know
shared out to his fans for them to come
out you know a lot of fans came out that
his head see me on Joe Rogan in
different podcasts and you know I just
feel really grateful to those guys
pretty pretty neat to just be able to
you know be in some funny circles with
those with that with with those crews
but this is serial-killer country up
here and people don't realize that and
so that's why I know that I was being a
little bit brave going out there to see
a man who said he had some hamsters
outside of town cuz that is I mean let's
be realistic that's the number one
that's like I got candy in the van
first there's candy in the van second
there is yeah I got a I got a you know a
small warehouse full of hamsters on the
edge of town oh sure oh really guy oh
I'll be right out but man thank you guys
for being here with me thank you guys
for start my week off okay and just you
know I feel a little bit better than
when I started
few minutes ago and that was a real call
over there from Vince and we thank you
Vincent and we wish you well over there
Germany you know and uh and I wish you
guys well in the Olympics I'm gonna try
to tune into some of the Winter Olympics
you know Valentine's is this week and
you know I want to say I want to wish a
special a special Happy Valentines to
all the single mothers out there and I'm
gonna I'm gonna make sure to order some
flowers or something from my own mother
you know there's something you know must
be tough for a lot of women if you in
I'm speculating here and I'm sorry that
I'm a man speculating about women I
don't know if that's I mean they might
take me to jail in your country
Vincent you know it's almost like it's a
like this is a speakeasy now like men
have to go to podcast to share some of
their real thoughts but we need more
women to stand up for men that are okay
out there and to tell these you know
these feminists who don't have real any
role in feminism is fine feminists
someone can get a little out of line and
some of it's a marketing ploy and you
know I just don't I don't need the pole
I don't need the wool pulled over my
gender eyes I don't need that we got
enough [ __ ] going on when you're trying
to get me to hate men and then sell me a
[ __ ] book at the end of it all eat a
dick dude eat a can of damn hamp [ __ ]
and you know how many would be in that
can probably could you even imagine
I bet 700 to get a whole can small can
too one of the ones you get black olives
in those little cans with a little you
know almost like one of those things at
those the Campbell's that you cook in
the microwave immediately those little
cups like that ooh actually probably
1,100 HAMP [ __ ] in there but hey hey
tan men for no reason that's not helpful
anyhow let's uh let's hit some other
calls here man we had um another call
here about porn although someone's gonna
talk to you guys about yeah and I just
forgot about it he's talking about going
out there and getting murdered but yeah
some of your famous murderers are from
up here you know you got green room
or killer you got you know you got
Jeffrey Dahmer I think it's from up here
you got [ __ ] you probably got 30 serial
killers I've never even caught that are
from up here so a lot of them from from
this area where I currently am so it's
pretty interesting I think let's get to
the second call right here I'm not gonna
be able to make this a really long
episode guys I'm safe I start taping a
pilot tomorrow for Comedy Central and
and we got some really great guest stars
that are gonna be on it
Bobby Lee is gonna be on tomorrow and
I'm excited about it so I'll let you
know when we're able to share that and
and it's kind of based on the podcast
loosely so I'm just so grateful to you
guys and and we're gonna do you know
we're gonna continue to do some some
really neat stuff oh but I was talking
about Valentine's sorry I wanted to wish
a Happy Valentines to all this to the
single mothers out there you know and
I've said this before that the you know
the hardest working woman that I've ever
known the hardest working man that I've
ever known was my mother you know and a
lot of responsibility fell on my mother
and I didn't recognize it when I was
young a lot of responsibility fell on
her to be a mother and a father and it's
not fair you know it's not fair for a
lot of these women who are single
parents to have that pressure it's not
fair because as a child you you have no
choice but to look to your mother a lot
of times if only your mother is
available for both for both parents for
you know to be both parents and there's
nothing and as a child you can't control
that you need to have your needs met you
need your world needs to make sense it
needs to feel okay and your mother can't
she can't beat two people she can't you
know and so I think yeah especially in
my generation oh there's been a lot of
disconnect sometimes between sons and
their mothers where we feel like we
didn't get enough from our mother you
know but a lot of times well we don't
realize that our mother was having to
play two roles and she probably didn't
realized it at the time just a lot of
pressure on
some of the mothers of my generation of
kids immuno my age and I just want to
say thank you to all the single moms out
there that I know it's a tough job what
you do and that you are loved and you
are loved not only by your own children
by by other children out there who had
single mothers as well and it doesn't go
unnoticed and we love you and thank you
very much and happy Valentine's Day
happy Valentine's Day to you from me and
from all of us out here from all of us
we were very grateful it's all the
single mothers out there all right let's
get into a couple more calls here and
then I got to get out of here guys here
we go
this call came in hey what's up Theo
this is Alex from Chicago I just want to
talk about some dark arts I'm trying to
not jerk off a lot I've been there
brother I've tried to not touch myself
and I used to one of the first things I
did and this was stupid I remember
putting like nuts Tapatio on the side of
my penis cuz I thought I was gonna do
well because I thought that if I touch
my penis my hand would get hot and I
wouldn't want to masturbate right I'm
like oh if I touch it it's gonna burn my
hand but you don't think that also
that's gonna burn your penis when you
put it on so that was crazy had to put
my dick in a frickin cup of milk and
then in a rag got a poor bunch of milk
and a rag and then closed put the rag
over my penis as well and put a bunch of
milk on top of it to get the you know to
get the burning out and I was that was
back in the day - I was also you know
how to eat a couple quaaludes to get
through that onward just wanna kind of
compare notes with you you know I know
you're trying to do the same thing you
do have any tips do you have any apps
that block porn websites on your phone I
don't have any apps I don't use them
there are they are out there you know I
um I noticed this though that oh well
when I I mean one thing you could do is
put that Tapatio when your wiener and
that'll make you not [ __ ] touch it
for about two weeks that's for sure
because it someone might have some burns
on the side of it and I'm not giving you
that you know don't do that because if
somebody you know don't do that please
but yeah I remember eating a couple
and waking up off that Tapatio you know
I'd done a little bit light basting on
the side of my own piece and waking up
and just having severe not severe but
[ __ ] you know pretty decent burns you
know probably category two or something
burns on the side of my pecker and you
know and a lot of fear and then I had
that milky rag next to me I know what
was going on I thought I got damn him
you know I think I got molested by a
[ __ ] ice cream salesman or something
you know or some dairy addict but anyhow
let's hear more I'm kind of drunk right
now with my buddy let's see what he has
to say about that you know Theo its
trigger words trigger words what was its
trigger me like if you is the same
nipple
all solitaire Dark Arts dimple if you
say quit I'll take it Dark Arts quit if
you didn't mango I'm thinking fruit you
know I'm just a human yes Sophia if you
got any tips to avoid those dark arts
you know in terms of pornography I don't
know sorry I don't even know what was
going on there your buddies sound like
he has a lisp like he got a heavy Lisp
you know like his daddy used to you know
I don't know you know sell pieces of
metal or pieces of wood or something you
know and you know he don't sound really
super genetically confident but I'll say
this dude you don't want to jerk off
first of all spend time with your buddy
the buddy system it's just like going to
the bathroom right you go together
everybody safe but if you stay up all
night with your buddy you're probably
not gonna jerk off I noticed as well get
into a relationship man I know that
sounds crazy but I find that if I'm with
a woman that I care about I don't feel
that that that scary vibration inside of
me that wants me to go and spray out and
do self spray you know and polish myself
until joy flies out of my car I don't
feel that same thing but whereas if I'm
by myself at home I do that I'll eat a
bunch of chocolate or fill my mouth with
[ __ ] you know coconut butter or
something
[ __ ] just beat off until my penis is
all hot but don't use that Tapatio
that's for damn sure
but if you really want to do it man you
just have to see you have to set some
goals there are some nofap websites and
I'll try to put that link on the YouTube
as well here we go let's take uh where
we at timewise oh we're at 51 man look
here's what I want to talk about for
Thursday and maybe for the next you know
week or so and I didn't get to talk
about it today if if there were a war
between the states which state would win
you know it appears sometimes like we
are headed you know apparently a lot of
people refuse to look at other people's
perspective and understand what other
people's lives are like so with that
being said it creates that continues to
create a lot of tension and I think one
of the first things that are gonna get
attacked they're going to be these news
networks they will be taken out of
commission but after that it could be
every state for themselves with that
said which state do you think would win
you know hit the hotline let me know
which state you think would win and why
and I'm gonna piece together a if we
were to get into a state on state war
every state for themselves who winds up
at the top or who ends up at the bottom
if you have a couple of ideas you know
hit that hotline nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three and and we'll
get into that and we'll see what's going
on I had some other calls that came in
but I'm have to address them on Thursday
man I love you guys and I appreciate it
I have one more show here in Portland
tonight and it's been it's been an
experience man we had a kind of a wild
experience on on Saturday and I don't
think I'm gonna talk about it I don't
think it's healthy maybe but it just um
you know it's just comedies a wild game
you know we're all living our lives and
we're all you no matter what's going on
world is trying to be okay
you know when it's funny in the world I
feel like so much so much so much of the
time we try to feel different you know
we want to be different I want to be
different
but I don't know if that's true I think
all we really want to be is loved you
know I think all we really want to be is
accepted and sometimes we're just trying
to be so different just so we'll just
stand out just enough so that we hope
somebody will see us and say man I love
you you know I love you or I accept you
or you're okay you know we all struggle
it's amazing the thing is that I feel
that we have the most in common with
sometimes is struggle I don't know why
that is I don't know but this week it's
happy Valentine's Day and happy happy
Valentine's need all the single mothers
and all the single fathers out there I
know I left you guys out sometimes I do
I'm sorry
happy Valentine's Day to all the single
fathers if you have a special
Valentine's Day experience as well hit
that hotline and we'll drop some of
those on Thursday as well nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
maybe we'll do that first but I'd love
to get you guys as thoughts on both of
those things so if you have a good
either one of those things if you have a
good Valentine experience or or
something or if you want to tell
somebody you love them something special
you know
you know maybe hit the outline or I
don't know that might be weird because
we're this the episode will be on
Thursday and it'll be Valentine's will
be over but yeah if you have some
thoughts if you're lonely and you do a
tradition or if you had a great
Valentine's and and you found a great
way to show somebody that you love them
hit that hotline let us let us know what
it is if there's something you do
special for your mother or father on
Valentine's or something special that
they did for you growing up hit the
hotline let us know what it is but just
know this today man that this week get
out there and allow somebody no hate in
this one change the way if you if you
starting off that Monday rocky take a
deep breath and say I don't you even if
everybody in the world or if I feel like
the world hates me today I'm gonna go
out there and love it
it's all we can do sometimes man and
especially this week this
stupid country bro this is Valentine's
when you got that little naked baby
running around with that [ __ ] bow and
arrow you know I'm saying that love Isis
that little do got you know [ __ ] in his
pants but he's out there pop pop pop pop
pop gunning gang gang Thank You Austin
Robinette Thank You Oregon Thank You
everybody that came out there everybody
gutter smut to 12 fat Gary you know cat
Bush earnest spice rack dead family
Gucci 11 Allen's small Pat everybody
Raymond little ice in Safa everybody
everybody that came out Derek Troy
butters everybody get that hitter man
god bless you guys be good to yourselves
you probably deserve it
[Music]